there have been scenes of jubilation in
mali after france said it would begin to
pull its troops out of the west african
country france has helped in the
struggle against radical islamic
militias for nine years until relations
with mali's military leaders turned sour
paris objects to their alleged hiring of
a russian mercenary group to fight the
jihadists but for now there's a sense of
relief in bamako
in the streets of bamako malian's wave
brooms and sweep away ash symbolizing
the departure of french troops after
nearly a decade
french president emmanuel macron
announced the withdrawal of
anti-jihadist forces on thursday after
months of escalating tensions with
mali's military leaders
but his initial timeline of four to six
months is now under question
mali's army-led government has expelled
the french ambassador and demanded the
immediate departure of both french and
european forces
on the streets the mood among the
government's supporters is clear
[Music]
if france wants to leave it must do so
immediately
no question of four or six months
we don't need france france has been
with us too long get her out
popular resentment against france has
been driven by its failure to stem the
tide of jihadist attacks in mali
their withdrawal potentially opens the
door for talks between the government
and the radical islamist forces it
opposes